are humans designed to be monogamous I  feel like anyone who's trying to disrupt  relationships I really admire that I  think that we have this one size fits  all toaster model of relationships where  if you think about a toaster you buy it  at the store you plug it in you never  expect it will get better why can't we  think about relationships more like an  iPhone where there's software and you  can constantly be getting more apps and  you can be deleting apps how can you  adapt and grow as the relationship  adopts and grows and so I would say I  have lots of friends that are in ethical  non-monogamy relationships who have  found that this is something that they  love to think about and talk about and  so I personally believe that there is a  lot of space to explore different  relationship structures